the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so um so let's get started okay so
um great we're here to talk about
cryptocurrency engineering and design I
think the first question that comes up
that's very obvious is what is a
cryptocurrency so this word was kind of
invented ten years ago when I don't know
how many of you know the origin story of
where Bitcoin came from but basically a
pseudonym on the internet dropped a
paper and some open source code in a
forum on an email list and said hey I
have this idea for this thing called
Bitcoin it's kind of like electronic
cash here's how I think it could work
and here is some code if you want to run
it and become part of this peer-to-peer
network we don't know who this person is
this person is basically virtually
disappeared from the internet and from
the world but it's created something
that has captured so many people's
imaginations and has sort of you know
depending on how you measure it created
billions and billions of dollars of
economic value and sort of inspired a
lot of people to think about how to use
this technology to solve a myriad of
different problems not just electronic
payments so you know crypto currencies
and the technology behind them are
inspiring people to think about how to
bank the unbanked add more auditability
and traceability to our world
get rid of trusted intermediaries and
institutions in certain situations and
you know basically solve every problem
if you read if you read about what block
chains can do on the Internet now that's
not exactly what this class is about
this class is not gonna be about
applications this class is going to be
about technology and infrastructure
you're gonna learn how to create a
cryptocurrency what goes inside a
cryptocurrency what's important what are
the techniques and you know what
application you choose that to apply
that to down the line that's kind of up
to you but we're not going to be doing
digital identity or healthcare records
or something like that we're gonna be
talking about the technology so a big
question is how are cryptocurrency is
different from regular currencies and
another thing that I want to make really
clear is that the term
in this space are still being defined so
you will hear people throw around all
sorts of terms cryptocurrency blockchain
consensus and and and these words are
kind of have floating evolving meanings
right now part of that is because
Bitcoin the first cryptocurrency didn't
come from academia as far as we know it
came from a community of enthusiasts on
the internet and so it doesn't
necessarily have the same basis and
rigor that we might expect from most of
our academic fields of study it's
totally okay we're figuring it out as we
go along
and academia is really embracing this
topic so if any of you are graduate
students who are looking for an area in
which to do research I think more
basically the number of papers published
on cryptocurrencies and blockchain
technology and respected academic venues
is doubling every year so there's huge
opportunity here so cryptocurrencies are
not regular currencies you know they're
not a dollar or pound or a euro what we
normally think of as currency there's
something different Bitcoin was sort of
created out of nowhere and and what does
it mean to create a cryptocurrency you
know who says you can create a
cryptocurrency what backs a
cryptocurrency why is it valuable well I
think in order well first before we
answer that question I just want to make
it really clear what this class is not
about okay we are not going to help you
I see oh if you are interested in IC
owing just you just go like this is not
that's not what this bus is gonna be
about we are not going to offer any
trading advice we have zero opinions on
whether you should buy Bitcoin now or
sell or whatever you know Zen cash or
whatever all these things are so like
none of that don't even ask us we're not
interested and this class is not really
going to be about permissioned
blockchains
either now you might not know what this
term means yet and that's totally okay
but I just want to make it clear that
what we're talking about here are crypto
currencies they're open permissionless
systems in which there is a token which
has some value so that's what we're not
going to do in the class so going back
to and let me just pause there for a
moment let me
and ask you if there are any questions
so far about what I've said yeah no not
at all and let's start to get into that
so the question was do tokens always
have to have value so I think really to
understand what our cryptocurrency is
what are tokens what do they mean we
have to talk about money okay and we
have to talk about what money is and
what it means so this is gonna be very
hand wavy and I'm sure not very
satisfying to a real monetary economist
but you know money developed there are a
few different theories about how money
developed there is this thing called the
coincidence of wants so maybe I have a
sheep and tag has some wheat I am hungry
and would like to make bread
Tadgh would really like to make a
sweater and so we can barter we can
trade you know I have won one set of
goods that is useful to tag cash is
another set of goods that are useful to
me we can get together and make an
exchange so that's fantastic barter is
incredibly important it barters existed
for a long time but what if you know tag
doesn't have weeped tag has vegetables
and I don't want vegetables I want wheat
but tad still wants the wool from the
Sheep how do we execute this trade we
don't have a coincidence of wants we
don't actually want the exact same thing
from each other so some theories are
that money evolved out of this problem
and money can be represented in so many
different ways it's it's it's it's
several it's from money I think was
first created around 5000 BC so it's
really really really old the things that
represented money usually had certain
properties they were rare they were they
were not easily reproducible people at
times used things like shells or bead
beads for money you know the first coins
this is like a really interesting coin
that was developed precious metals were
often used for money and then eventually
we sort of evolved into what we think of
as money now which is paper bills
currency another theory of how money
came about is
this idea of receipts debt and credit so
you know maybe I have a sheep and I
share all of my sheep and collect a lot
of wool what I can do is I can store
that role somewhere and I can get a
receipt from someone from having stored
that wool and that receipt is a value it
entitles the person who holds the
receipt to the good that is being stored
and it and and so another theory of
money is that money evolved out of these
receipts trading these receipts back and
forth instead of taking all that wool
with you you leave it in one place in a
depository and the receipt acts as a
bearer instrument whoever owns it has
access to the wool in the depository and
so you can kind of see two different
ideas about what money is develop from
this one is well it's it's a bead or a
coin or you know something that I hold
something physical that we've decided to
assign value to in and of itself and
another idea is I'm going to use a
trusted institution I'm going to deposit
something with that institution and they
are going to ensure the validity of that
deposit and manage who has access to
that deposit so this doesn't really get
it the question that was originally
asked which is why do tokens have value
but one thing I want to point out is you
know why well a question I want to ask
you guys actually is why do these things
have value does anyone have any ideas
yes because everyone agrees that they do
any other thoughts on why those things
have value
they're backed by institutions say a
little bit more about that what does
that mean okay the government's coming
too promising to respect the value of
that does anyone want to add to that or
have another reason yes and see your
name payment for taxes okay so that kind
of connects to the government thing okay
great
anybody else yes they have value because
they're rare okay interesting all right
so those are all really interesting
ideas I think that those are all sort of
properties of what makes things value a
valuable there are definitely things
that are rare that are not valuable
right I can think of some things you
know that that might be extraordinarily
rare there's only one or two of them
universe and you would have no interest
in owning them whatsoever
you wouldn't assign value to them
certainly it's really important that you
can pay taxes with this stuff because
taxes is you know pretty much a
requirement of living in any country
there are things that have value that
you don't necessarily use for taxes so
that's that's a little confusing and
then there's this idea that it's backed
that it's backed by something right and
you know the dollar used to be backed by
something and actually if you look at a
dollar I think it still says this right
it's backed by The Full Faith and Credit
of the United States government they
don't say that anymore they used to say
that but that's what like a lot of
people say about about money it's backed
by the by the Full Faith and Credit of
the United States government you know
what does that really mean I think what
it all goes back to is these things are
valuable because we think they're
valuable we've all decided they're
valuable and you know that if you have a
dollar bill and you want to buy
something from someone they're gonna
take it that's gonna that you
can make that exchange and the reason
that they're gonna take it is because
they know that someone else is going to
take it right these things hold value
because we think that they hold value
it's it's a collective story that we all
tell so I think once you look at money
that way then when you start to look at
tokens which are essentially digital
representations of these things things
that are rare and a little bit special
then when you ask well why does this
token have value because we think it has
value so what makes a token inherently
valuable the fact that we think it's
valuable and a lot of different things
can go into that maybe we think it's
valuable because it you know it's very
rare or maybe we think it's valuable
because someone's promised that you can
use it to pay for storage like with
Dropbox or maybe we think it's valuable
for a completely different reason
because we like the name or we like the
people who are running the network but
ultimately tokens are valuable these
digital representations are valuable
because we think they're valuable yes
well so my argument is that the fact
that they're limited is something that
goes into our perception that makes it
valuable great ok so now that we've
learned a little bit about money talks a
little bit about money I want to go into
how payments work because ultimately
we're gonna get to cryptocurrencies and
cryptocurrencies are electronic cash so
here's the way that digital payments
kind of work right now you have an
institution called a bank you have Alice
and you have Bob and Alice and Bob have
accounts at this Bank right and so the
way so the bank is keeping track of sort
of who owns what and these are these are
records these might be digital records
they might be paper Ledger's or paper
records whatever the bank is using to
keep track of sort of who has what in
their account and so the way that I've
set up this example right now Alice and
Bob both have bank accounts Alice has
$10 with the bank and Bob does not have
any money with the bank
so let's say that Alice wants to pay Bob
let's say that Alice and Bob have gotten
together maybe they're in the same
coffee shop and Alice wants to buy a
sandwich from Bob and Bob says okay you
need to pay me a dollar if you give me a
dollar then I'll give you the sandwich
so how can a let's do this
how can she transfer a dollar to Bob
well if she had a paper dollar she could
just do that right but you know let's
say that she doesn't have a paper dollar
so Alice can ask the bank to make this
transfer for her or five dollars so
Alice sends a message to the bank and
authenticates with the bank and you know
to show the bank that she is in fact
Alice but I'm not going to go into the
details on how that works and then the
bank confirms that makes the transfer in
its ledger says Alice now has five
dollars and Bob now has five dollars
Alice tells Bob hey I did this I talked
to the bank go check you can you can
verify it for yourself
Bob checks with the bank and sees yes in
fact the bank is saying that he has five
dollars now whereas before he had zero
and then Bob gives Alice a sandwich
because he believes that he now has five
dollars and the bank sort of preserved
the property that money was not created
out of nowhere that that the balance was
ultimately maintained so the bank is
very important in this scenario the bank
is critical this is how digital payments
work credit cards venmo banks it's kind
of all sort of based on the same idea
that there's some trusted institution
that is handling that payment for us and
that is keeping track of everything now
what are the pros and cons of this
scenario anyone want to throw a couple
out yeah
around
right so we're putting a lot of trust in
this bank and maybe you know should we
trust the bank banks fail sometimes
banks are hacked banks have humans who
are running them who occasionally might
want to change those balances in their
favor this has all happened anything
else yeah yeah there's a lot you know I
almost have to talk to the banks and
that's kind of annoying so there's that
anything else yeah so okay so this is
like getting a little bit more advanced
here you know what if everyone takes
their balances out at the same time well
you know we need to make sure that the
bank actually has that money so to speak
we're not gonna be talking about that
problem right now but very good problem
so to kind of talk through some of the
pros and the cons of this situation one
of them one of the big pros I think is
that even if Allison and Bob are not in
the same physical location
Alice can still pay Bob if they can talk
to the bank so that's pretty cool and
that's something that you can't do with
dollar bills or with coins or with bars
of gold right so having the stress of
institution that you can communicate
with electronically means that Alice and
Bob could be halfway around the world
from each other and they can still pay
each other so that's that's pretty
awesome and that is definitely a
property that we want to have in terms
of cons I think we covered quite a few
of them which is you know we're really
putting this Bank kind of in the middle
of everything here and there are a few
different ways that that can cause us
trouble
so the bank needs to be online during
every transaction if the bank is offline
then how does Bob know whether he got
paid or not the bank could fail at some
point in time which is kind of related
to that the bank could simply decide
that they don't want to do this anymore
and can block transactions and then
privacy the bank has kind of insight
into everyone and their payments and
this is like incredibly sensitive
information payments are quite quite
important and we're gonna be talking
about privacy a lot in this class during
the second half of this
so just like an example a couple of like
visual examples of that the bank could
just totally go away and then what
happens to that ledger who knows right I
mean literally it could just disappear
it's just you know maybe it's paper and
it gets burnt or maybe it's bits on a
computer and it wasn't replicated um the
bank could decide that they don't like
Alice for some reason and that they
don't feel like processing Alice's
transactions this happens all the time
in the real world so there have been
designs for electronic cash that that
work a little bit differently and and
we're gonna kind of step up to the most
sort of like the design that came right
before Bitcoin and we're gonna do that
iteratively so let's talk about ecash
and how he cash works so the way that
ecash works is Alice tells the bank
instead of saying hey Bank do this
transfer for me Alice says hey I would
like a digital representation of a coin
can you give me something that is
digital so I don't have to be in the
same physical place as you and that you
know that I can use in such a way that I
can prove to someone else that I have
this thing and then I haven't double
spent it because that's the problem with
digital representations of coins like a
fundamental problem is that bits can be
copied so whatever system you use to
design your electronic cash you need to
make sure that people can't just copy
coins and give this what what is sort of
the same coin to multiple people in the
previous example the bank was making
sure this happened the bank was
maintaining balances and you know Deb
debiting Alice's account and crediting
Bob's account but you know if we want to
think about something that doesn't
involve the bank and we're starting to
get there then we need to think about
you know how to ensure that a coin can't
be what is known as double spent so
Alice asked the bank for coin and you
know maybe she does that maybe she has
an account with a bank like before or
maybe she gives the bank teller like
actual physical money in order to get
one of these coins so the bank generates
a unique number s n stands for serial
number and decides that this is the
physical this is the digital
representation of the coin
then gives that coin to Alice in a way
that it's clear that the bank did this
usually this is done using a technique
called digital signatures we're not
we're gonna get to that in as class
progresses but not right now
once Alice has this coin then she can
give it to Bob and Bob can take a look
at this coin and hopefully there's
enough going on with this coin that Bob
can be convinced that this is a real
coin Alice didn't make it up out of
nowhere she actually had the funds so to
speak to give to Bob and that it hasn't
been double spent and with traditional
ecash the way that this was and and once
Bob is convinced of that he can give
alice to sandwich now in traditional
ecash the way that this is done is Bob
actually goes back to the bank and says
here's this coin Alice just gave me this
coin you know is this an OK coin but the
fact of the matter is that the bank in
this case has a serial number and knows
that it gave that unique serial number
to Alice and then Bob is showing up with
a coin that is that serial number and
what the bank is doing here in this
example is the bank is the way that the
bank checks to make sure that this coin
is correct if it looks at the serial
number and it makes sure that it hasn't
been spent before right so the bank can
link the coin between Alice and Bob
which is unfortunate the bank can also
the bank also kind of still sort of has
to be on line not to do the actual
payment between Alice and Bob but in
order for Bob to have confidence that
this coin is real and and you know later
on Bob can say you know I would like a
dollar for this coin that I've just
given you or something like that or Bob
can have an account with the bank and
can maintain a balance there so just to
kind of like go through some of the pros
and cons here oK we've kind of done
something where the bank's not in the
middle except the bank is still really
in the middle we're getting like a step
closer but we're not we're not there we
don't need you know the the Alice can
technically give Bob this electronic
thing that represents value but Bob
still needs to talk to the bank to make
sure it's real and it hasn't been
well spent and we still have this
problem where the bank is the one who's
minting these things the bank can decide
not to give Alice a coin if it feels
like it and we still have this privacy
problem because the the secret number
the serial number that we invent for the
coin can be linked across these payments
so there's this notion of something
called Chow me and E cash so David
Chapman was a cryptographer and he
developed the system which has slightly
nicer properties than previous forms of
ecash so the idea here that's really key
is instead of the bank choosing the
secret number Alice chooses as a secret
number and we have ways of generating
random numbers that we can be fairly
sure are unique so we can let everybody
generate their own random numbers so in
show me an e cash Alice chooses the
secret number that represents a coin and
then Alice blinds her message so Alice
adds some randomness to the secret
number such that the bank doesn't know
what that number actually is and we'll
get into more detail about exactly what
that means that's actually it's it's all
in the paper that was assigned reading
for this class so make sure that you
take a look at it so when the bank
verifies that the secret number is a
real secret number and it's really a
coin and Alice gave the bank of dollar
or something like that the bank does so
on the blinded secret number and Alice
actually has the ability to remove that
randomness or that blinding later and
end up with a valid signature on a
secret number so Alice does the same
thing that she did before she gives Bob
a representation of that electronic coin
and when Bob redeems it
note that the bank never sees what the
number is so when Bob redeems it the
bank has no way of linking the payment
between Alice and Bob so just to get
into how this works visually Alice will
talk to the bank and Alex will use a
blinding factor on the secret number and
so when Alice talks to the bank the bank
doesn't actually see what the secret
number is they can't decode it again
Alice gives a dollar or something like
- to get this coin from the bank and the
bank signs this Alice can remove the
blinding factor later and this is what
the coin is the coin is a valid Bank
signature on the secret number and also
the number itself which Alice can then
send to Bob Bob can check and make sure
that this is a valid signature from the
bank and if that's correct then Bob can
give Alice a sandwich in order to redeem
this Bob gives this coin to the bank the
bank says okay I've never seen the
secret number before so I'm gonna assume
that it's you know and you have my
signature on it so I'm gonna assume that
I went through this process with
somebody and you know signed something
and now I'm gonna record that secret
number once that happens Bob can be sure
that this coin hasn't been spent before
the bank keeps a running list of all the
secret numbers its seen and it makes
sure that if it ever sees one again it
can it can say no this is this is not
correct this I should never see a secret
number more than once now okay but we
you know what about Alice could give one
version of that to Bob Alice could also
give a version of that to Charlie and
how are Charlie and Bob supposed to know
what you know whose coin is correct
because remember we wanted to try to get
the bank out of the way when doing this
and so in Chow me an e cash the way that
this works is the bank actually keeps a
bit more information and the information
that the bank is keeping won't let the
bank link these transactions together
unless Alice happens to give this to two
people and so if Alice gives the same
coin to two different people the bank
will be able to detect it and the bank
will be able to know it was Alice and so
this is kind of a motivator for Alice
not to do that so the idea being here is
that the way that we get around the fact
that we don't know if a coin is has been
double spent or not is we we add
punishment if the coin is
spent so bob doesn't know for sure that
this coin he receives hasn't been double
spent but he does know that if it was
someone's gonna know it was Alice and
they're gonna punish her so this is a
pretty clever scheme and this actually
gets us around a lot of problems we have
digital payments we can make the actual
transfer without the bank in the middle
we have some privacy now because the
bank can't link transactions together
and we have this way of doing double
spend detection we have a way of
motivating people not to double spend
their coins which means that you
probably don't have to check at the time
you receive a coin whether or not it's
been double spent of course this still
suffers from a really big problem which
is that a bank can still decide that
they just don't want to do this with you
they can just decide that they don't
want to play this game with you they
don't want to issue coins they don't
want to maybe they don't like you
specifically maybe they don't want to
take your coins and exchange them so
this scheme tchau me and ecash solves
quite a bit of problems when it comes to
how do we have electronic money with you
know some nice features but it doesn't
quite get to all of them and so the real
question in this class is how do we do
electronic money really in a
peer-to-peer way where there's no
institution in the way there's no sort
of entity that can say no
so he cashes the math is really
interesting it never really that kept
her allowing on these banks that's I've
never quite got off the ground so I'm
I'm going to talk about somewhat more
abstract and low-level primitives
I'm not going to quite get into cash or
you know tokens or transfers on or
anything this this lecture so but I'm
going to talk about the really basic
primitives that you need that we already
sort of mentioned hash functions and
signatures signatures obviously are we
talked about a little bit what you need
to be able to sign messages in order to
send these tokens around but first I'll
talk about hash functions which are like
basically the most fundamental basic
thing we use in these systems and I
think if you've used computers or if
you've programmed a little you probably
have some familiarity with hash
functions they're simple right but
they're actually extremely powerful the
hash function is basically you have some
data a bunch of bytes a bunch of ones
and zeros you run it through a hash
function and you get an output that's
also a bunch of ones and zeros generally
the input data can be of any size you
can hash something that's a mech you
know put in a megabyte put in a gigabyte
or put in a single byte and generally
the output is of a fixed size so in the
case of Bitcoin we use sha-256 the
output size is 32 bytes long or 256 bits
long and you know this is used for lots
of things in computers I guess the
reason they call it a hash is because
it's like when you take the potatoes and
chop them up into little squares and
grill them on the you know if for
breakfast it's sort of that idea that
we're taking this data and you know the
data going in gets chopped up and
smushed around and then comes out into
an output the properties so this is not
a sufficient different definition but I
will say that you can sort of do
everything with hash functions there's
some fun things that you can't do but
you could make a cryptocurrency only
using a single hash function and I think
people have like sort of for
experimental reasons if there's you you
limit the fun stuff you can do but you
can do signatures you can do encryption
you can do all sorts of things like that
okay so
this is not a sufficient definition
right that okay there's any size input
fixer size output and the output is
random looking that's sort of
wishy-washy but what is random looking
mean it's not actually random right if
you put in the same input everyone will
get the same output so if you say okay
well what's the hash of one you'll get
some output and if you someone else says
okay what's the hash of one you'll get
the same thing however the output does
look you know while it is deterministic
it's sort of high entropy in that the
output should have about as many 1 bits
as 0 bits if you take the hash of 1 it's
just gonna look like a big random number
and the hash of 2 will look like a
completely unrelated random number the
outputs look like noise so if you've
ever seen hash functions you can run it
on your computer you say echo you know
hello pipe shock 256 sum and you'll just
get some kind of crazy random thing
there doesn't seem to be any order to
the outputs a little bit more
well-defined we usually talk about the
avalanche effect in the changing a
single bit in the input should change
about half the bits of the output right
so even though you have extremely
similar inputs they should be completely
dissimilar outputs well completely
dissimilar as in about half the output
changed if every bit changes then it
just is the inverse of what you had and
so it's easily correlated but the
avalanche effect is is sort of how hash
functions are constructed we're
generally there iterative rounds and so
you say okay I'm gonna sort of swap
these things and multiply these things
and shift these bits around and such
that if any change in the beginning will
sort of propagate an avalanche to so
that all the output bits have been
affected by it
okay and a little bit more well-defined
generally the hash functions are defined
by what they should not do so that three
main things they should have preimage
resistance second preimage resistance
which I'll sort of skip over and
collision resistance and we can define
what these things are okay so a
pre-image is the thing that came before
the output so it's sort of a mathy term
but the
is okay if you know why you can't find
any X such that the hash of X is equal
to Y so if I give you a hash output and
that's all I give you you should not be
able to find an input that leads to that
output so if I just say hey here's a
hash output it's you know 3 5 o 2 1 FF
whatever you know some long string you
won't be able to figure out what I used
to put in to get that of course you
can't find it eventually right therefore
for any given Y there's probably some X
in fact there's probably a lot of X's
that will lead to that Y since Y is a
fixed length and there's you know 2 to
the 256 possible wise but there's an
infinite number of X's right because X
is not bounded in length you can have a
megabyte or a gigabyte or a terabyte
size X so since there's sort of infinite
numbers of X's and a fixed though a very
large number of Y's you know as long as
it is a random mapping there will be
lots of different X's that can lead to
this Y and so you should be able to find
it it's just impractical right it's like
yeah maybe you'll be able to find it but
it's gonna take you 2 to the 256 tries
to find any specific Y value and that's
about 10 to the 78 which is a number
that's big enough that you can sorta
round it up to infinity well I mean not
quite but big enough that you're not
going to be able to compute that right
the Sun will burn out and the universal
diet stuff like that so that's pretty
much resistance you can't go backwards
given the hash you can't find what what
led to that ok any questions about
preimage resistance seems reasonable
it's a little interesting in that given
y is a little tricky and then it's like
okay well someone came up with you know
someone might know X in order for them
to have computed Y or maybe it's just
completely random and no one actually
knows what the X is right so so there's
a there's a sort of loss of information
in the idea of a pre-image stack ok
second preimage resistance
this one's a little trickier and and can
get messy so I'll define it but we won't
go into it too much the idea is given x
and y such that the hash of X is equal
to Y you can't find X Prime where X
prime is not equal to X and the hash of
X prime is equal to Y so we're sort of
giving you a pre-image we're saying hey
here's this number X and here's this
result Y I bet you can't find another X
that leads to it this one is actually
poorly defined in the literature and so
it's like it's literally like well who
made X and who gets to choose and is it
any X Prime and things like that so and
it's not actually that useful so we can
just sort of gloss over that one just
just sort of mentioning it and then the
the other one that's very proper that's
very important is collision resistance
where the idea is that nobody can find
any X Z pair such that X is not equal to
Z but the hash of X is equal to the hash
of Z and this one's sort of a lot
cleaner in that there's no lack of
information there's no like secrets or
anything it's just like look no one can
find this and so it's really easy to
disprove you can just say hey look
here's an X and here's a Z try hashing
them oh shoot the hashes are equal and
it doesn't really matter how you got
these or who's doing it so that's a
really nice easy clear property and
again you can find this eventually right
so if your output size is 256 bits long
you'll be able to find two inputs that
map to the same output in fact you do
not need to try 256 times I not gonna go
into the details but you actually only
have to try a hundred and twenty-eight
times to I sorry two to the 128 so you
need to take the square root of the
number of attempts in order to find this
collision because sort of the intuitive
reason is well you just start trying
things and keeping track of all their
hashes and there's what's called the
birthday attack which as you keep trying
them there's more possibilities so you
know the next thing you try you can
collide with any
of these things you've tried before and
so you actually only have to do the
square root and it's called the birthday
attack because um there's sort of the
birthday paradox which is not really a
paradox put the ideas so in this room
there's people that have the same
birthday it's almost certain which seems
kind of weird because the intuitive
thing is like well there's 365 days a
year maybe once you get like a hundred
50 6070 people in a room you're gonna
have two people with the same birthday
but actually it's like 22 or something
anyway that that it becomes likely that
people will have the same birthday so
it's kind of counterintuitive and and it
applies in this case as well so to find
a collision you need the square root of
the output space but you know a hash
function should not have collisions if
you can find a collision if any
collision exists for this hash function
you can consider the hash function
broken it's a little bit different than
premature assistance because it's hard
to sort of definitively prove that
you've broken four images that's
something of an interactive process
where you say hey here's a why and then
someone comes back with an X oh okay you
proved to me that you can find free
images but that's hard to tell - the
rest of the world because it was sort of
interactive whereas collisions are very
clear and non interactive you can just
say hey here's an X and here's a Z
anyone can verify these you don't really
matter how you got it okay so sort of
some practical how do these functions
work practically speaking the collision
resistance is a harder property so there
are many functions where the collision
resistance has been broken where the
preimage resistance has not been broken
so examples of this are sha-1 and md5
md5 is a fairly old one written by ron
rivest over it well I guess it wasn't at
the Stata Center because it was in the
80s but this was you know message
digests 5 I guess there were several
before that and that is quite broken you
shouldn't use it
it's collision resistance is you know
trivially broken you can find collisions
and like under a second on a modern
computer sha-1 was more you know
happened later in the late 90s I think
and the NSA made it and there
there have been collisions fact I think
there's really only one collision that's
been found
basically by a team at Google and some
Italian University last year and they
they spent like a lot of computer time
to find this collision but they did find
it and then once you find one it's sort
of like oh yeah we really shouldn't use
this anymore but in both of these cases
sha-1 and md5 there's no feasible
preimage attack so given a hash output
for either these you can't find what the
input was or you can't find a different
input so generally it's it's a lot
easier to make a function strong against
preimages collisions is sort of harder
to do we deal with also practically
speaking how do these hash functions
work it's a little bit of black magic
there's no proofs that a hash function
can even exist right so if you could
prove if you can prove that there is a
one-way function you would you you get
the Fields Medal right it's like a
million-dollar prize so if you can prove
that there is such a thing as a hash
function like you will be a super famous
mathematician we have no idea that this
is even mathematically possible or you
know maybe the universe doesn't work
this way it seems to though it seems
like there are these things that work
like hash functions that work like
one-way functions but we have no proof
of that so so even the most fundamental
part of that that everything hinges on
we don't even know if it exists so and
then this is sort of closely related if
you're in the computer science e stuff
to like P and NP that like anyway so we
don't we don't know that these actually
work and and also in practice there's
the hash functions are sort of not nice
math cool things like elliptic curves
and like RSA prime numbers and stuff
like that they're really like if you
look at the code it's sort of like well
I'm gonna take these bytes and I'm going
to swap them and then I'm gonna add
these two numbers and then I'm gonna
rotate the bits over here and then I'm
gonna XOR these things and then I'm
gonna do that 50 times and why 50 well
it seems like 50 is a good number it's
not too slow like so no really like it's
sort of black magic shot 256 uses 64
rounds nice even number different
functions like Blake to be uses 20
rounds but then
also a version that uses 12 rounds which
is faster and people think well it's
still seems quite secure but if you want
to be really secured use the 20 round
variant if you want to be probably
secure enough use the 12 round very so
so this is not like there's no proof
there's there's heuristics and things
like that and best practices but it is a
little like this kind of cryptography is
a little bit black magic and it's not
based on any cool like mathematical
number theory stuff either the way that
elliptic curve cryptography or RSA kind
of stuff is so like if you break RSA you
can say hey I can now factor these you
know composite numbers very quickly
that's in of itself a cool mathematical
discovery the breaking of sha-1 there's
not really any cool math insight it was
just like yeah we found this fairly
specific weird path that we were able to
break sha-1 after a couple years of
computer so it's cool and some people
are super into it but it's something of
a niche to like actually build hash
functions I would recommend not building
your own national yes and my question is
is breaking a hash function literally
just guess and check where is there so
so know if you so like break if you say
hey I found a collision by doing one two
to the 128 attempts one nobody's done
two to the 128 attempts that's still
seen as like beyond technology today but
if that's how you break the function
that's not really considered a break
because that's sort of the definition
it's like yeah well we know this is 256
bits long so to find a pre-image if you
do 252 to the 256 attempts you'll find
it so that's not considered a break a
break is considered hey I I found a
pre-image in two to the 240 attempts or
I have a proof that you can you will be
able to find a pre-image in two to the
240 attempts and here's how to do it and
that's considered a break even if you
know it's still impractical to the 240
is still impossible in today's
technology but that would if you had a
paper and people looked at it like oh
yeah that would work you wouldn't be
able to do it but that's still
considered broken and so those are
different class
okay so so something like md5 md5 oops
output size was 16 bytes or 128 bits so
collisions even if even if it were you
know strong it would still be sort of
too short today that collisions would be
able to be found in two to the two two
to the 64 iterations which is doable on
today's computers like if you rent a
bunch of stuff on a TBS you can do to
the 64 in a couple days so so but like
that's sort of the different definitions
of breaking the function sort of fun
Ethan Hellman who's at BU and we work
with he and we all sort of broke the
iota wrote their own hash function which
is like some crypto currency and we we
found collisions in it and it's kind of
fun but yeah it was like weird it wasn't
like number theory was just like oh I
wrote this Python script and then we
have this go script and we you know
tried this thing we got a collision so
usages what do you use these sasser's
for there's lots of cool things you can
use it for it you can use them sort of
as names or references where instead of
naming a file you can just take the hash
of a file and that is a good
representing you know a good compact
representation of you know so you can
point to what you're talking about so
the hash of a file is a unique
representation and if you change any bit
in that file the hash will change and so
you know that okay here's this you know
way to point to the file you can also
use it as sort of a reference or pointer
in different algorithms so you can say
like you know anything you're using
pointers for linked lists or like maps
and stuff like that you can say well I'm
going to use a hash and as a pointer and
then be able to like sort through it
that way so these are so anytime you
sort of think of pointers and thin like
graph theory and stuff like that in
computer science think well could I use
a hash function here instead of just a
like regular memory pointer and in many
cases you can in some cases you can't so
you can't have cycles right since the
idea is you can't find free images you
won't be able to find a whereas you
could make
you know a cycle of pointers in the
computer where like a points to be be
points to see see points back to a you
shouldn't be able to produce that with
hash functions because having that cycle
means okay well somehow you found this
preimage right but but in many cases you
can do this and then another way to look
at is the hash is a commitment you can
sort of say well I'm not going to tell
you what X is but I'll tell you what Y
is and I can reveal X later and then
since everyone remembers why they can be
sure that yeah he's revealing the right
thing right he's there are no collisions
in this function so we can be sir if
were presented with X that this was the
X that was committed to yesterday
so I'll give a little example of that
I've sort of commit and revealed so you
can commit to some kind of secret or
something you want to reveal later and
reveal the privilege so here's my
commitment I'm this is an actual hash
sha-256 I just made it on my computer
and there is a string you know there's
an ASCII string that maps into this and
it is a prediction about the weather but
that's all I'll say
and like given that information and
given this hash you probably can't find
my prediction you can try to try all
these different ascii strings about the
weather today but i'll reveal it
okay so i think it won't snow Wednesday
but it actually anyway and then I put
this number it and so if you you know
put this in your computer and Linux I
think in Mac it's a slightly different
come in it's like shocked to something
or something but in Linux this will work
and you can say I I think it won't snow
Wednesday and then I put these some
random numbers here because if I had
committed to just the phrase I think it
won't snow Wednesday you might have been
able to guess that right you can say
well he said it was about the weather
I'm gonna you know take all sorts of
built millions of different strings
related to days and weather and like
common English words and I'm gonna try
hashing them and see if I find a
collision and you might be able to write
but I added this four bytes of
randomness at the end to make that
difficult it doesn't really contribute
to my commitment
I sort of you know you know the list
doesn't really mean anything but it
makes it harder to guess what my input
was you know cuz I've already revealed
that it is it's not a fully random input
right so you might be able to guess
things like that
so I could you know I could say hey I'm
gonna make a prediction about the
weather commit to it and then reveal my
prediction tomorrow and we'll see if I
was right this can be useful in the case
where like you know not the weather but
in other things if if knowing my
prediction could influence the actual
events this would be a nice way to you
know commit to what my prediction is
without everyone knowing what the
prediction is and then revealing it the
next day yes
hashing this again well in so in Bitcoin
they hash everything twice it's it's
like generally you don't need to there's
no explanation for why they do that in
Bitcoin you could but there are things
you can construct where you can say like
append some extra data and then hash
this again so you could say here's my
prediction for next week and like this
is the hash and then lash it again so
you can make sort of chains of
commitments and then reveal iterations
of it actually I only had some slides
where you can sort of you know hash
something again and again and start
revealing it incrementally that might be
useful I actually have stuff like that
in software I've written where you want
to reveal secrets but you let's say I
want to reveal secrets but I don't want
everyone to have to store all of them so
I can sort of make a chain of hashes
commit to the last one and then as I
reveal six successive free images you
don't have to store all of them you can
just store the like the latest free
image and you can reconstruct all the
hashes from that
so to evaluate like if you want to try
this it it's imperceptible to perform
one shot to p6 hash is I don't know
billionth of a second or something you
can do you can generally do like a
hundred two megabytes to a gigabyte of
hash output on a regular CPU core she's
asking does it make it harder to find a
pre-image if you hash twice oh the
answer is sort of note it it might so
like I don't know chained md5 can you
still find collisions I'm not sure but
but generally you're generally thinking
is if the hash function is broken and
you can either find collisions or
preimages yeah maybe it gets a little
harder by chaining like by iterating it
but you should just stop using it and
use something that's secure but yeah it
seems that like finding preimages would
be harder since it's essentially adding
more rounds right by hashing it twice
and then there are some attacks so it's
like fairly out there but um it's called
length extension attacks due to how
function hash functions are constructed
where if you do say okay I'm gonna take
the hash and then take the hash of that
you do prevent certain types of attacks
that are like fairly niche but like a
length extension attack you know you
know merkle-damgard construction will be
prevented by this so generally no
generally you don't need to do this but
there are sort of different
constructions where you're gonna hash a
bunch of times I don't have the slides
here but like a Merkel tree is a binary
tree of hashes where you're sort of
taking the hashes of these things and
then hashing it again and again and
that's a really useful data structure
and a blockchain is essentially a chain
of hashes and that's what we'll talk
about next week
but yeah okay so I'm gonna go a little
faster so that's that's an interesting
use case where you can commit and reveal
and yeah
adding randomness so you can't guess the
preimage this is called a hash based
methods message authentication code
where there's part of it a secret and
part of it not and this is kind of a
proto signature this is getting towards
a signature right where I've committed
to something and then I reveal it and
everyone knows yeah that's that must be
what he committed to the the day before
it
not quite a signature but it's getting
to that direction and so next I'm going
to talk about signatures
what is the signature it's useful and
it's a message signed by someone and so
I'll define what a signature is through
the functions that it uses there's three
functions will allow you to create a
signature scheme generate keys sign and
verify and so these and these different
things generate keys you make a secret
key and a public key and so the idea is
like there's some public key which is
your identity and there's some secret
key which you only control and you use
that to sort of prove your identity and
prove these that these messages are
signed by you
so yeah you generate a key pair
the holder of the secret key can sign a
message and then anyone possessing the
public key can verify a message
signature pair so I'll go into detail on
these three functions and this is this
applies generally so I'm going to talk
about a hash based signature in detail
but there are many different signature
schemes DSA el-gamal RSA signatures
elliptic curve signatures there's tons
of different cool math systems that that
allow that these kinds of functions and
I'll talk about in some ways this is one
of the simplest ones okay so yeah
there's these three functions the first
one is generate keys and it returns a
private key public key pair and it
generally doesn't take any arguments but
it takes in like randomness you need to
flip coins you need to find random 1 and
0 bits so you know and there has to be
long enough that no one else can guess
what your private key is ok so you have
a private key public key public key is
you know public key tell everyone
private key is or secret key actually I
think I in the code I always say secret
key it's usually better to say secret
key because at least it starts with a
letter that's not P anyway ok and then
the signing function where you take your
secret key in your message and it signs
a message and returns a signature
okay and this thing you know all these
things are just strings of ones and
zeros right it's just a bunch of bytes
public key a private key a signature a
message these are all just bytes right
and then the verify function which is
sort of the most complex a verify
function takes a public key that you've
seen a message and a signature and it
returns a boolean whether this was valid
or not so it returns a single bit if
it's zero it says yeah these things
don't match up either maybe maybe the
message just changed or maybe the
signature has changed or maybe it's from
a different public year something but if
all three of these are correct you know
and the signing function was the private
key the secret key associated with this
public key was signed this message and
produced this signature than it will
return true and so you can get into the
sort of math properties of like okay how
what does it mean to forge a signature
and like can they be Forja Balcon pute a
tional e like eventually a lot of these
things since it's bits you could
eventually guess the forgery but maybe
that takes two to the 256 attempts or
something okay so any questions about
the basic structure of like what
constituents a signature scheme or
mostly makes sense and you can see how
this is useful you can say okay you know
you can publish a public key and say hey
I'm Tadgh this is my public key and in
fact on my business card I have a RSA
public key and so if people get my
business card and then I sign a message
and email to them they could be sure
that well this is probably the same guy
nobody ever cares but but you know and
you know it's useful for the stuff we
were talking about before with like
chomi and cash where alice needs to
authenticate to the bank and one way to
do it is to sign a message and say hey
I'm Alice give me a coin and then Alice
can sign a message to Bob and so on so
this is really useful as a basic
building block for all these kinds of
messages okay
so I'll talk in the last 14 minutes
about signatures from hashes this is
doable using just hash functions you can
construct a signature scheme and in fact
that's the first
problem-set and you implement a
signature system using only hashes and
the hash function is already defined for
you it's in the standard library
it's just shot 256 the same thing
Bitcoin uses and this is called Liam
port signatures Leslie Lamport
wrote about this late 70s I forget
exactly when the paper came out but this
was one of the earliest cryptographic
signature schemes and it's kind of cool
and it works another fun thing is it's
quantum resistant so if you know about
like quantum computers quantum computers
kind of ruin all the fun in terms of
cryptography all the cool things we can
do with cryptography not all but most of
them get ruined by quantum computers but
hash functions are quite resistant to
quantum computers because they're not
based on any fun that they're based on
this black magic of just you know X
whoring and shifting numbers around
that's a huge oversimplification but but
yes those hash functions are generally
seen to be quantum resistant so if you
have a signature scheme that only uses
hash functions well it still works even
if someone invents the quantum computer
and can break all these other things
like RSA in elliptic curves so there's
actually sort of renewed interest in
these kinds of systems recently ok so
how do you make a signature seem with
just hash functions so how do you
generate a key in this case so a public
key and a private key you want to
generate right so first we generate our
private key now
these squares are 32 bytes each just and
you generate 256 of them on this row 256
of them on that row so you're generating
256 times 2 or 512 32 byte blocks right
and these blocks are each 256 bits or 32
bytes so in total that's what 8k 8
kilobytes I think pretty big but anyway
you're saying okay here's my private key
it's all completely random I just you
know take debt slash dev slash you
random or whatever just flip coins 8,000
times or however many this is total and
generate all these different blocks and
store them on my hard drive
and keep it secret then I want to
generate the public key so for each of
these 32 byte blocks I take the hash of
it which will also be 32 bytes and I you
know take the hat so there's now 512
hashes 256 on this row to 256 on this
row the Green will be my public key okay
and the grey one is my secret key so
they all look the same they all look
like just a bunch of random ones and
zeros the gray ones actually are a bunch
of random ones and zeros the green ones
are actually hashes though of all the
great ones and I publish the green ones
you know I just to serialize it I just
put in a row I just say okay here's this
first 32 minutes second third fourth and
then go to this row or whatever scheme
you want okay so how is this useful now
everyone knows a bunch of hashes and I
know a bunch of the preimages right and
I don't so now it's sort of this commit
reveal thing where if I reveal to you
this you can verify that oh yeah that
mapped to this one right later on okay
any questions so far about this process
seems sort of useless but fairly
straightforward okay then I want to sign
so first to sign a message I'm gonna
take the hash of the message to sign and
this is often done it's done in Bitcoin
it's on and most signature schemes where
I want a fixed-length number to sign so
I don't it's it's annoying to have to
say well what if I want to sign a
megabyte long file or what if I want to
sign up ten byte long string you want to
standardize it so look I'm whatever I'm
signing it's always 256 bits long right
so if I want to sign the message hi
first I take the hash of the message hi
which in shot 56 is this is the hash of
hi and so I look at this as 256 bits and
I say okay I'm gonna pick the private
key blocks to reveal based on the bits
here so the first bit here is a 1 right
because it's an 8 and so I'll reveal and
and I indicated before that there's sort
of this zero row and this one row and
now what that means is okay well the
first bit of my message to sign is a1 so
I'm going to reveal this gray square and
the next bit the next four bits actually
since it's me are going to be zero so
I'll reveal this and then I'll reveal
this this and this and I just made it up
but like yeah so for example if I'm
signing and it starts with 0 1 1 0 1 1 1
0 I reveal this free image this pretty
much the screen is this pretty much
these 3 this one
and so I reveal pre images based on the
bit representation of the message I'm
trying to sign and then give everyone
these so so my signature will just be
this sequence I can I can go in a row
order here yeah it's probably a lot
easier so I go in sequence I say okay
here's the first 32 bits of bytes of my
signature here's the next here's the
next here's the next and so my signature
ends up being 256 blocks long each of
which are 256 bits so it's like 8k wait
the keys are 16 K and this is a fairly
big but totally doable on a computer
today right hey kilobytes is no big deal
okay now to verify take the signature
hash each block of the signature and see
that it maps into that part of the
public key right so the people who are
verifying the signature they have your
public key they have all the green
squares and now they have been given a
signature which is these gray squares
and they say okay well let me hash this
one oh it maps to that so it maps to a
zero
oh this maps to a 1 this maps to a 1 its
maps to a 0 and they can go through and
say yeah this is a message this is a
signature on that message right in the
case of limp or signatures you can
actually determine what the message is
just from the signature and the public
key right since you're given these you
know if you're given this and you're not
told whether it's a 1 or a 0 well just
compare you know hash it and compared to
these two green ones you'll be able to
see and that's a useful signature okay
because no one can forge that because no
one knows these pretty images except for
the person who holds the secret key so
given your public heat I can't forge a
signature from you once the signature is
issued I also can't forge a signature
right the only bit sequence I know is
the one that you revealed and so I know
part of your private key I know half of
it right but the aisle I only that half
only lets me sign the message you just
signed so I can't really do anything
extra with this so this is a usable
signature scheme
any-any I think I just showed it but any
downsides that you can think of with
this is that what your signatures are
sort of public so yes you're saying that
um you can sign a message once and give
it to a bunch of people and that's sort
of a feature not a bug I guess there are
different signature schemes where you
want like I only want this signature to
be valid to this person there's
different ways to do that with like
diffie-hellman key exchange and stuff
but generally the the signature scheme
we've we've talked about here with these
three functions the public he's really
public and anyone can verify and that's
that's something we want if you don't
want that there's other ways to do it
but yeah the big one is wait you can
only sign once as suit once you generate
a key pair your private key your your
public key and you tell everyone these
green squares if you try to sign again
if you'll reveal more pieces of your
private key right so if I sign two
different messages sometimes it it's the
same bit sometimes it's different bits
and now I start revealing more pieces of
my private key and now people can start
to forge signatures because I can say
okay well the first bit I can I can sign
anything right on the first bit I'm
still constrained here and here and here
but in several locations
I can I can you know I can sign
whichever bit I want and so
the the basic thing is if there's one
signature
I can't Forge anything if you give me
two signatures since it's generally you
know random on average half of the bits
of the signature will be constrained so
in this case if it's 256 bits long and
you signed twice I probably still can't
Forge anything because 128 bits I have
the freedom to pick either and on the
other 128 bits I'm stuck with either a
won't you know either the one or the
zero and I don't get to choose so mote
that means most messages I want to sign
I won't be able to write because it's
gonna like if I try 102 to the 128
attempts I'll be able to find a forged
signature but that's a lot and so maybe
you can sign twice but again it's
probabilistic you might get unlucky and
reveal quite a bit more than one you
know 128 bits where you get both but but
on average and then once you have three
signatures okay now I've probably
revealed three-fourths of the locations
you're gonna have both the one and zero
row and you can start and that this
starts to be practical because this in
this case it would be you needed two to
the 64 attempts to for this to forge a
signature and that's that's doable on
today's computers
you